I'll be home at six sharp.
If you need anything,
call.
I mean you can
love you.
Sweet Mimi.
Mimi call if you need it.
Yeah,
they bought it.
Pardon me?
Why I have a strange envelopes.
I you a couple of baboons.
What are you looking at
breaking the fourth wall.
It's one of the most unique,
the devices at the disposal of a
filmmaker.
Most cinematic techniques pull us into a
story and make us forget we're watching
a film,
but breaking the fourth wall does the
opposite.
It reminds us we're actually an audience
member watching what's happening on
screen.
I can't believe we're paying.
It's he jumped in.
We get on TV for free.
If you,
me,
everybody in this theater is a giant
sucker.
It's your,
the technique can contribute to the
visual storytelling of the film in many
different ways depending on how it's
presented.
To really understand the power of
breaking the fourth wall,
we have to look at its inception and
theatrical performance.
It's crazy.
Now a formal definition for breaking the
fourth wall would be a dramatic
technique and a work of fiction where
characters display an awareness that
they are in such a work.
You might say every one of us is a
fiddler on the roof.
The technique goes as far back as
ancient Greece and continue to through
Shakespeare time and well into
postmodern.
A theater,
especially in musicals,
the term first arose after the use of
box sets became popular in the 18
hundreds when sets were constructed with
three walls.
The fourth wall being the imaginary wall
between the audience and the performers
on stage.
So whenever a character acknowledged the
audience's presence,
the fourth wall was
rope.
The technique has been used since the
silent era and Charlie Chaplin played
around extensively with fourth wall
breaks in his films.
With the introduction of sound and the
popularity of the musical genre,
fourth wall breaks became more common to
contribute to the spectacle of film.
And over the next 70 years,
fourth wall breaks have made their way
into a variety of film genres with a
variety of thematic effects.
Do you all see me all dancing crab?
The most popular use of this technique
is for comedy and the comedy stands out
by creating some of the most memorable
punchlines in cinematic history.
Oh,
do you?
Yeah.
That's funny because I happen to have
mister McLuhan right here,
so,
so yeah,
just let me,
let me,
let me come over here second.
Oh,
I heard what you were saying.
You,
you know nothing at my work.
You mean my whole fallacy is wrong.
How you ever got to teach a course in
anything is totally amazing.
Boy,
if life were only like this,
right,
there's something really surprising and
hilarious
about reminding us that we're in the
middle of watching a film.
No matter how many times I watch a movie
break the fourth wall,
the joke can still catch me by surprise.
The joke has to step out of the film to
deliver the punchline,
and there's really no other type of joke
like it.
Every other joke is enclosed within the
imaginary world of the art form.
Taking that step out of a movie is what
makes a good fourth wall joke.
So satisfying and creative.
That's where I see things just a little
differently contract or no,
I will not bow to any sponsor.
I do want to note that breaking the
fourth wall,
it doesn't automatically make you a
comedic genius.
The setup and delivery of a fourth wall
break has to be at least somewhat
surprising are the joke can come off as
kind of Lazy Jay and Silent Bob Movie,
Eh,
I suggest you don't worry about this
sort of thing and just enjoy ourselves.
That goes for you all to yes,
Eh,
what it was.
Now be miles.
I bought
hello,
good evening and welcome to the middle
of the film.
Much better.
You can't talk about breaking the fourth
wall without mentioning Mel Brooks.
He broke the fourth wall in the most
extreme ways possible.
We see the script.
His films go so far as to actually have
the main characters watch themselves
within the movie.
What the hell am I looking at?
When does this happen in the movie?
Where all,
what do you want to do now?
Come home.
Let's check out the end of the,
Gee,
I sure hope there's a happy ending.
Well,
his films are funny because of the
ridiculousness.
There's definitely some method to his
madness.
I like a blazing saddles uses fourth
wall breaks to poke fun at the western
genre as a whole.
It really points out how unrealistic
Hollywood films were in their portrayal
of life in the West.
In reality,
western films were nothing but actors in
a studio acting and fake towns and
eventually getting into a car to drive
off the sec.
Blazing Saddles is a not so subtle
reminder that film as an art form has
its limitations at portraying reality.
Mel Brooks made a statement by pointing
out the lack of realism in the western
films.
Western films of the forties 50s and 60s
almost completely ignore racism,
xenophobia and other ugly parts of the
West and blazing saddles breaks the
fourth wall in an insane way to remind
us we're watching a dramatize film.
Not Reality.
Could've thought of another way to get
us here.
There we go again.
We're wrong.
Perhaps what makes breaking the fourth
wall the most intriguing is that
depending on context,
the act of acknowledging the audience
can actually push us into the film.
Instead of pulling us out.
There's a sort of intimacy to a
character speaking directly to us in
road to Morocco,
bing crosby and Bob Hope.
Make lighthearted jokes straight to the
audience and even to remind us that
they're going to end up fine on their
adventure.
Who's we may meet.
We haven't any paramount,
well pro tech does cause we're signed
for five more years.
We know from the casual and inviting
fourth wall break set.
This is a movie that doesn't take itself
too seriously and will provide light
conservative entertainment.
Fourthwall breaks can be a way to
welcome us into this story and this
variation of the technique is definitely
indicative of a more casual movie
morale.
A fourth wall break can make us intimate
with a character as well as with the
story.
There's really no stronger way to show a
character's motives.
Then by having them look right at us and
save them.
I go for 10 I'm probably going to have
to barf up the lung.
I better make this one count.
It's a great way to show us what's going
on in the character's head and is
comparable to an aside in feeder.
Frank Underwood addressing us directly
is the foundation for so much of the
energy in house of cards.
Good and Donald don't let this get you
down.
Why together we're going to do more than
you've been able to do in 25 years.
I left the scenes where he says one
thing to another character and then
looks at us and reminds us what he's
really after two things and now
irrelevant.
I don't blythe and Donald Blinds,
new drafts.
Eventually I have to rewrite the bill
myself forward.
That is the battle cry.
Leave ideology to the armchair general
was does mean no
final great effect of breaking the
fourth wall is to unsettle.
There's nothing scarier than feeling
safe and removed from the villain in a
movie and then having that villain look
directly at you.
I hope they are watching.
They have c see,
and they'll know and they'll say,
hi,
Shane.
Look,
Nathan Hammons,
decks,
comedy,
satire,
intimacy,
and fear can all be accomplished just
from a look to the camera.
So don't forget the great potential of
fourth wall break can have.
And thanks for what
w.
W what were you doing in here?
This is my room.
Get Out,
get out and making the video.
Get Out.
Hello.
What does the guy have to do to get some
privacy around here?